[Musique]
des adieux dans la plus pure tradition
des églises afro-américaine célébration
de la vie de dave cloyd source
d'inspiration et de changement bref
hommage à l'homme devenu symbole des
inégalités raciales mais aussi à big flo
l'ange du quartier qu'onéreuse de
houston le super héros de la famille
[Musique]
un cri du coeur les proches de john
floyd considère sa mort comme un meurtre
est un crime haineux
10la du chase no magic race prise sur
ces micmacs grighine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
éloge funèbre du militant pour les
droits civiques en choc tonnes un
message aux américains qui s'opposent
farouchement mouvement d'égalité raciale
et quoi encore
m et il travaille martine bry onat et
l'heure des funérailles que les
afro-américains on trouve souvent vu au
fil des décennies mais l'espoir que
cette fois les choses changeront que la
mobilisation réussira à leur apporter
justice et égalité oui à 4 m
[Applaudissements]
le cercueil doré a été transporté dans
un cimetière de la banlieue de houston
kyle floyd a été inhumé aux côtés de sa
mère celle qu'il appelait à l'aide
juste avant de mourir
[Musique]
ici philippe leblanc au canada juste
ya cent
[Musique]